hello tiger biome 24 year old guy that
has zero game the Asian version of PD
that's Georgia version of you but I am
looking at that t-shirt now for the
first time the great cornholio that's
right I've been dating my first
girlfriend for six months now and she is
a handful she's ungrateful
unappreciative is selfish and at times
but I still love her that's it
I however am a [ __ ] sweetheart I
don't have I don't have the guts to tell
that she needs to calm down and just be
nice to me for once how do I approach
this one you just have to bite your
tongue and just go through what you get
your ass wipe you get fed in bed and
wine bucket well wipes my ass I'll
[ __ ] finger that you have to deal
with all of it
so basically gives yourself a asian
woman bro you just have to accept it and
just pray and not snap and just go that
you're you know that you're the good one
you know that you're the good one you
know that she's acting the way she's
acting right and you just have to accept
that but there's nothing you can change
about her cuz that's the way she is I
love how it's just impossible to believe
that the woman is actually the same
person in the relationship is that so
hard to believe what are you getting
angry for me and I'm just responding I
deal with I never [ __ ] to do as a reason
and also on top of that [ __ ] you I'm
just saying that has nothing to do with
our relationship I'm George responding
to his thing alright so I'm just saying
in your situation I know that your girl
is acting insane and homicidally and
like unreasonable and you have to just
kind of go swallow it and go that's yes
I say man up tell her give us some
warnings if you don't respond to them
but that's the thing you warned her
though you
that is talk to her nicely hey you know
hey you know Anna Anna Anna and I
haven't always been good at like
communicating but this is a great
opportunity to communicate yeah you know
and and like say hey man this is not
fair you know this is [ __ ] up and she
may or may not respond and like why are
you dating somebody it doesn't care
anyway
also don't listen meet me in Edwards
because I'll tell you why
all right this guy's a [ __ ] machine
what that's what I've been told well you
hate I'm just saying you I'm just saying
let me just say this right now I want to
say something to you right girl right
now I'm not gonna say her name
I listen it she's young very pretty
right and to any normal guy your age cuz
you're 50 she's 19 you be like I'll be
like so yeah you sure nobody came up to
you in that showing South all I'm saying
is is that he's not the right guy to get
you know advice from I mean how how far
you'll never be that never be a 50 year
old [ __ ] how's the machine I'm just
saying how far is is is he gonna be is
he unhappy how old is he first of all we
got to know the age bro my thing is Oh
24 he was like oh but I'm a sweetheart
but but most girls around that age I
like that so you gets another one he now
says that right and how come he doesn't
get his head bitten off what do you mean
most women that age are like yeah cuz I
was we're all yeah we're raging
alcoholics at that age we just want to
[ __ ] and everyone smiles sometimes they
don't grow out of it
that's great see this
[Music]